here last week I asked you to send
anything food related let's see how you
guys did you know I flexed a little bit
this week with my meatball cooking
skills and a lot of people were jealous
they were judging me
they were hating on me oh you can't oh
you can't use a metal spatula with a
Teflon plate [ __ ] up oh you may very tan
me both with a [ __ ] make it vegan oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry
I enjoy the flavor of it a little bit
more literally bunch of crybabies my god
oh I'm a chef and this made me cringe oh
I'm sorry I didn't dedicate my life to
this very one thing I bet you my
meatballs tasted way Savior than yours
way fresher than yours way fatter way
love fear way browner way better than
yours go home okay now weird that we're
done with that let's judge what you guys
did with food last week all right what
am I looking at here I totally caught me
off guard what what is oh I see it now
this drawing is very nice very nice
drawing
I put tomatoes in my cheeks very nice
and bananas in my hair very nice and
chillies in my beard
very nice Peeta pie after YouTube it's
food-related so you get zero points
because it wasn't funny shut up I don't
look like that
I literally created a reddit just to
submit this original content whiskey
tasting you laugh you lose well you
forgot to add crafting videos and
cooking videos thank you very much
oh that's not original content for you
literally crime or you're all a bunch of
crybaby [ __ ] I bet you're sitting
sucking on your mama's titties what
happened to me Christine Channel
Christian Channel goddamn Felix gosh
darn Felix why do you have to annoy me
so much
hey Mars day I turned myself
there's a damn big meatball if that is
Edgar for a scale reference helmet
Christine chocolate okay all right now
that looks good
beauty perspec yeah yeah disrespecting
women no zero deaths heck yeah salty
breath all the way that is some fine
Photoshop right there
papi pixel as always well done what
kegger you want to eat those huh you
want to eat those that means he likes it
what is up guys my name is Peter Pat
how's it going bros my name is Peter
what's up guys it's your boy well done
okay you made me you made me chuckle
well done what do you want an award for
chuckling that's not a thing that's not
a thing you can go now bye stop what
that do something did you post this
summary of Peter pie this channel
doesn't have any content can we get one
nice one can we just get what I'm sure
there's one nice one in here Swedish
meatballs with Irish potatoes it looks
delicious
I'd eat that want some noodles listen
here you how do I say this
how do i emphathize how stupid you are
stop calling spaghetti noodles okay this
is spaghetti this is spaghetti
this is noodles learn the difference
it's not that hard
Asian European Asian you're a pain you
racist cultural appropriating
son-of-a-bitches oh they want some
noodles no I want spaghetti forget it I
want spaghetti not noodles it's not that
hard okay I want to call you a bunch of
[ __ ] retards but I can't cuz I'm a
Christian Channel oh my god it's a
parity banana you seeing this Edgar that
looks just like this is [ __ ] this is
sexy
this is hell heck yeah man this is some
nice very very excuse me while I assume
in on my face and I say oh my Lord and
Savior beauty pie
I'm the Savior gentlemen we can rebuild
him we have the technology release too
bad well done you win this one wins by
default
AMD 159 for my neighbor you're my
neighbor buddy when they tell you the
private line will be finished within 47
days but it's 2046 jacksepticeye has
reached 50 million subs Brad is finally
not salty in pub G Elon Musk has been
announced president of the first Mars
country and you still have [ __ ] Internet
can someone please save me from my
betting today it's not funny anymore I'm
not even joking I just want to die whoa
Edgar Maya cupcakes with psychedelic
slippery interior oh that's so cool what
I don't even see that that's so dope
okay
okay you're a cupcake what's that you're
black not brown oh my god you're racist
listen here listen here we're gonna have
a talk later tonight that is amazing
thank you very much for our free I want
to eat that that looks good I would eat
egg here if you know to me that was a
weird joke I don't know what PewDiePie
after too much food oh my god it does
look like me what the heck who is that
man
well it looks like I have a bright
future ahead of me look at that man
stunningly beautiful nice chair noob Pro
you making fun of my chair you're making
fun of my pristine beautiful gaming
chair but you can't even get laid it's a
bride scum level insult a very nice food
meme Mars yeah
Wow you are so clever well done oh look
at those [ __ ] Jeffy whoa
I've seen this on Twitter it's so cool I
don't know how it's done but now locked
thank you
I love how you guys accept the challenge
man it's so fun to see so cool I bet you
it was delicious I bet you it tastes a
savory as my balls and my meatballs the
meatballs that I cooked in my vide thank
you very much
it's what I'm trying to say Christian
Channel when your channel Christian as
[ __ ] and you're trying to make means
about to eat and you shall never be
monetized that's right I'm the Savior
from the unpack ellipse if my meatballs
you will be saved
top 10 hottest anime muffins look at the
thickness in my legs goddamn and made me
laugh so hard Marseille is really
enjoying remember markiplier
jacksepticeye defeated by this is them
now feels yeah that's funny
well then I have been waiting my whole
life to submit this Carla brofist into a
nectarine that's cool I didn't know you
could do that I didn't know you could
carve in nectarines but that's cool I
bet that nectarine was savory as my
alright last page I've been really
impressed this time you know I wasn't
I'm not that disappointed what a nice
PewDiePie but where's the con I
need this I'd really don't you know I
could just stop I'm stopping there's
nowhere for me to go over there it's
just a wall but whatever you know what I
forgive you cuz I'm a Christian channel
you're welcome
take PewDiePie take food and smash them
together
no don't smash no no you know what
that's this rude man
why do you have a PewDiePie cut you know
what never mind
I made what I believe to be the dish
that best represents PewDiePie it took
10 minutes to make with low effort
tastes the same every time and his pure
work well I'm sure it tastes great when
you make a food challenge and look at
the submissions and realize your friends
are talentless losers and now you're
going to have to do another you laugh
you lose because you're out of content
ideas and then has to upload an edit the
same you know if you lose 4 times until
it gets monetized
I did seven times last time thank you
very much and can't when I get a lot of
bit of praise whatever I don't need this
I really don't need this what
brofist hard candy from when I was bored
at work wait how do you make this and
how do you make so many they look good
that looks amazing
that's awesome well done candy princess
oh my [ __ ] spit Christian chap PD PI
the Sims play horror make 1001 Lea
BuzzFeed complain on YouTube yella
come on I'm not I'm not that obvious
okay you never know what you're gonna
get
that's the point of the PewDiePie
channel you never know what you gonna
get you're welcome now I'm not like all
these mainstream channels doing the same
content over and over
okay I'll keep you guys on your toes I
keep you guessing I bet you didn't know
this video was gonna come up hmm I bet
you didn't know Kristin channel was
gonna take off that's right all right
it's time to end it here it was a good
show you hit all the marks unoriginal
content and more unoriginal content I
get it okay I get it my hair making fun
of my appearance
oh you think I'm so insecure if there
was a modeling contest I bet you I would
win it and if there was an IQ contest I
bet you I'm Rick and Morty and you're
Dora the Explorer okay so next time you
talk [ __ ] you know what next time talk
shits bring it okay next time I want you
to roast me and then post a picture of
yourself because then I will roast you
back if you dare if you even dare
consensually if you're over 18 and Marcy
allows it oh that's what I'm gonna do
okay so post picture see it was a tough
guy huh Sue's a tough guy maybe like if
you enjoyed this video thank you guys so
much for watching I love you guys so
much
squad fam